hey all it's kevin van oort here with
some quick impressions of the time I've
spent over the last few days playing
total war Attila which is due out in
February 2015 a little over a month from
now I was sad that the preview version
didn't let me play as the Huns but I did
want to get a taste of nomadic life and
so I chose another migratory group the
Ostrogoths and as it turns out life as
an austere goth is pretty dangerous
I began as a homeless horde but I chose
to settle quickly into an abandoned
settlement and sent my to pre-existing
armies out to conquer such settlements
aren't blessed with full fertility so I
knew that I wouldn't be filling my food
stores as quickly as I like I figured my
fledgling village might provide some
sustenance for the years to come but man
I was wrong the Hun's were having none
of it my visions of exploiting the new
Total War options of plundering and
pillaging were crushed I had to abandon
my dreams though I did come to
appreciate the ability to drop camp
anywhere and make a home for my
traveling horde it was as the sassanid
empire that I was able to explore some
of the games newer additions in greater
detail one of those additions is the
political system that governs factional
power struggles welcome worthy guests I
trust you bring words that will enhance
the honor of your people in our eyes the
goal is to maintain your ruling families
power and avoid the interference of
nobles that seek to usurp it for
instance you can assassinate nobles that
are giving you trouble or buy their
favor for me I found success in
assigning governorships to the grandees
and finding wives for my generals this
is all very simple to accomplish once
you grow accustomed to total war till as
busy interface understanding exactly how
these options affect your progress and
potency doesn't come as easily I have a
handle on the basics at this point but I
don't yet feel like the mastermind of a
grand political plan I can certainly
March with the best of them however in
one of my city's unrest broke out after
I failed to maintain public order and
thus the first sassanids civil war began
and the first battle that I had a chance
of emerging victorious ensued
fortunately I'd kept my armies healthy
and well equipped in spite of my
decisions to choose mostly civil
technology at a good array of troops as
well as three deployables of fire pit
and two sets of steaks which you can
place on the ground as defensive
measures
the prototypical total war battle ensued
featuring over a thousand men locked in
heated skirmishes the
rock-paper-scissors relationships
between units are easy to understand
it's good positioning and battlefield
management that wins battles well that
ends a bit of AI exploitation the
preview version of total war Attila
features many of the same hey I troubles
the previous games held along with the
usual performance struggles here's
hoping they're ironed out before full
release it goes without saying that i
was still invested turn-by-turn in the
future of my Empire not really a
surprise in a series known for absorbing
players for weeks months and years I
wish your own empires all the best for
when the game is fully released on
februari 17
you